cet espace rambouillet pour toujours
avoir plus de visiteurs ou au moins
autant que maintenant ça nécessite des
investissements importants entre 5 et 15
millions de d'investissement est
aujourd'hui malheureusement l'unef n'a
plus les moyens
de les avoir pour pouvoir investir
qui a envisagé c'est qu'effectivement il
y à un transfert de ce service à l'été
2000 22 le temps de bien sûr de
d'étudier les offres de discuter avec
les candidats le temps aussi d'avoir
n'est validation administrative et
réglementaire
[Musique]
des nouveautés possible qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui présente donc ce sera à
chaque opérateur de faire ce projet là
pourquoi pas de l'hébergement et c'est
immersif c'est des choses qui se
développe un peu partout dans certains
parcs animaliers mais ça sera
nécessairement dans le respect
du fait que ça restera une forêt
domaniale
deuxièmement que ce soit dans l'esprit
vraiment de de l'animal dans le milieu
et son aspect de tous les
réglementations ou si bien le
d'urbanisme que que tous les autres qui
puisse y avoir
[Musique]